hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
May 15
2023. what's going on how are ya
oh [__] it's Sunday it's happy Mother's
Day
um happy Mother's Day
everybody bows down to you woo but they
don't care about other people
obviously you got to give it up to the
moms out there
I was just like mothers for all the
things you do just I don't how you do it
how you find the time
you don't want to do that for engineers
I love it I don't know how you do it
what do you mean he's a [__] kid what
are you just gonna leave it there
I know how you do it you love it
[Laughter]
like Engineers I don't know how do you
do it how do you Dam up a river and
drown all those animals how do you know
how many people to tell to clear out of
the valley before it goes under [__]
400 [__] feet of water
how do you do it how do you do what you
do how do you know what to build the
[__] did how does the water not go
around the dam
[__] water
how how do you do I don't you know what
Engineers I don't know how you do what
it is that you do but I'll tell you this
I do know how a mother does what she
does
I don't find it confusing
I'm not saying don't respect them I'm
not saying it's not their day but I am
so sick of people like scratching their
heads like they just can't get their
[__] head around it
um it has nothing to do with being a
mother it has to do with how fearful men
are of an upset woman so you just have
to just constantly be gassing them up to
make sure God you got to make sure they
feel appreciated
if you [__] know anything
anything that oh my I I don't know how
you just sat down on that couch like
that I mean it's just you're you're a
woman I mean the wonderment of you
uh you know meanwhile you know
somebody's [__]
rerouting water from the top of this
state and we all down here literally in
these these metropolises that should not
even exist
the California Aqueduct people I don't
know how you I don't know how you did
that
I still don't know how you do it
I don't know why you did it either
should have [__] left this place
alone
um
how can we get a bunch of mouth
breathing
morons
to live in this part of the world so you
know we we fought a battle we we took it
over but now what are we gonna do with
it if we're not there the people we
defeated will gradually come back into
let's get a bunch of [__] let's get
some water down here we'll we'll build
some theme parks
I got it we'll have a factory right
that'll create jobs but it also serves
cake just listen to me on this one okay
cheesecake everybody's favorite all
right
everybody back here thinks of a factory
they think of [__] smokestacks and
[__] you know Miner's lung and all of
this [__] and I'm just you know gonna
get used up and I'm gonna die and some
guy in a top hat
you know
like Andrew Carnegie or Andrew Carnegie
if you're from Pittsburgh is going to
make all the money and then say I owe
the public nothing
that's what they think out here
our factories are going to make cake
I don't know if that's the history of
California but I'm going with that
um
anyway before I get too deep into this
Oh Billy new dates
oh Billy's got some new ones on the
calendar Billy new dates Thursday June
22nd 2023 what are you doing what are
you doing on Thursday hey everybody what
are you doing Thursday June 22nd 20
[__] 23.
are you going to be anywhere near
Hershey Pennsylvania
at the Giant Center and then July 6 2023
Allentown Pennsylvania
um Allentown Pennsylvania PPL Center
I'm at the PPL Center people in
Allentown Pennsylvania
that sounds like a [__] one of those
Pennsylvania towns that Billy Joel would
write a song about the blue collar
people
you know
and I'm out there on the Allentown
steamer
and I'm [__] got on my big rubber
boots and I'm doing this [__] I'm
[__] going over there and my wife is
a [__] [__] oh Lottie dog
say
or Saturday to the rest of the world
July July 15th
2023 Tacoma Washington
I'm doing the Emerald Queen Casino hello
and hotel
then we added one uh
the [__] am I doing out there Sunday
October 1st 2023 I'm in Springfield
Massachusetts at the Mass Mutual Santa
kid
and then Thursday October 5th I'm at
Niagara Falls Ontario at the Fallsview
Casino and Resort
now back in the day Niagara Falls that
was the that was the place that you went
to on your honeymoon
you know and if you didn't push her over
you stayed Mary
no that's what people would do
and back in the day you know the
original X Games
was people for publicity
to just show how daring they were
because back in the day being daring
could get you some [__]
right you had to be you had to be a
daredevil you know you couldn't just fly
a plane you had to get out of the
[__] thing while your friend flew it
and walked on the wings
hey ladies I want you to meet my friend
we don't want to make him he's a wind
walker a wing walker sorry
and next thing you know they're just
lining up
to give that guy syphilis
it's how it worked back then and there
was no cure for it
um so back in the day the original X
Games people would get in for some
[__] reason
the big thing was to try to go over the
falls in a barrel
to go over the balls the falls in a in a
barrel and and live
and then that would be you that was your
[__] thing
because there was no sitcoms there was
no movies or whatever there was well how
are you gonna get famous the only famous
people were were super like super rich
people Robert Barons the J.P Morgan's
the Vanderbilts the [__] Asters the
uh
the what's your favorite Andrew Carnegie
Carnegie in [__] Pittsburgh yeah the
robber barons The Rockefellers JD
Rockefeller right
that's when every white guy just wanted
to go by initials that was like some
[__] white pimp [__] back in the day
I'm HD Buttercup say nice to meet you
JD Rockefeller
get your hands out of your pockets
um anyway so if you're just a regular
person how the [__] were you going to
get famous
riding around on a horse robbing banks
and eventually you're going to get hung
you didn't want to do that you didn't
have the [__] balls
to join Jesse James of the younger gang
or whatever
of Billy the Kid that [__] lunatic
right
one of America's greatest spoiled brats
Billy the Kid
to a temper tantrum with a gun you know
one of the most American things you can
do I feel
um I don't know anything about any of
these people
um yeah you'd get a barrel if you're
just a regular [__] person
all right and you didn't you didn't have
the [__]
you didn't have the sack
you know to walk up to some chick in a
hoop dress
you know in a fan and a little parasol
and you came walking up you didn't look
like a gun fighter right you want you
know you weren't getting any so you had
to go out there and you had to go do
some dumb [__] but back then it was
called being daring
all right and you would get in a [__]
Barrel
you'd close the lid and you would just
float
and you'd go over the falls in a wooden
barrel
and you'd die there was one guy went
over the went over the falls one time
and on the way down he hit a rock and
got stuck
and then he was in there he either
drowned or suffocated I can't remember
what
there was one kid you know it's funny
there was one kid he actually fell out
of a boat had nothing on but a life
preserver he went over the falls and he
actually lived
so it really was like it was sort of
Russian roulette with a with a river
but uh that's what they did back in the
day the original X Games you know
there was no selfies around how would
you even prove that you did it
you couldn't sit there and do like you
know like those those influences on
YouTube
and you know they always turn them on
like is anything worse like when
something happens
and you just want to see the clip of it
and then you got to sit through that
YouTuber's [__] intro
you know like something whatever you a
[__] cow falls down a flight of
stairs
and lands on I don't know
I don't know some fat chick playing a
piano whatever I'm just spitballing here
right and that's what you want to watch
and then I'll then you click on the
video and then there's immediately some
[__] douche with his eyebrows up
going oh [__] you guys all gonna believe
this one okay in [__] Allentown
Pennsylvania they got a staircase right
now
okay you gotta [__] go it's just show
the video
I know what happened I don't need you I
speak English I can read the title why
do I need you to walk me through and
then the cop okay right here we're gonna
stop right this is where the cow starts
to fall
show it
it's one of my big
my big frustrations in life
um oh Billy can drink coffee again he's
he's off his little [__] fast here
and um
I gotta tell you I'm feeling like I
don't want it
I don't know what it is I just the last
couple of times I went to get off it I
had a headache I'm like what the [__] am
I doing here
you know having said that I'll probably
end this podcast and go get a cup but
like uh
I don't know I think I've I've had
enough cappuccinos to last me a lifetime
and uh
and now I started like following some
like coffee [__] on um
on Instagram and I'll tell you this I
don't
as much as I like food and coffee I
don't Vibe with those people
you know what I mean like the second
like the music that they play you know
that [__] music they play
for some reason whenever uh there's a
cooking video
like the music has to be like
it's perfectly dividing the line between
being happy and upbeat and just
absolutely mindless
you know and there's always some chipper
like [__]
you know she's hot but not in a hoary
way like in the kitchen right because
she's got to be the wholesome one
you know she's not going to teach you
how to make [__] food
to be all like pickles and hot dogs and
phallic shaped things
baguettes you know she's going to do
more of the wholesome things
um the wholesome cooking
oh my God wouldn't that be great
I think that's the only
cooking show the Food Network hasn't
done yet
just how to make [__] food what does he
say like what is that there's no such
thing as that but you can just brand it
like they do anything like how real
estate agents
you know there's some shitty part of the
[__] City
that the government doesn't care about
and they're not investing any money into
it or anything and then all of a sudden
you know they just keep printing a
trillion dollars every year with no gold
behind it and then white people get
forced out of their neighborhood that's
what the gentrification is it's the the
white people with the least amount of
money then getting forced to go to leave
their neighborhood that they didn't want
to leave
um they always leave that part out they
act like it's just like rich white
people moving in maybe it is I don't
[__] know um it seems to me like
you're getting squeezed out everybody's
getting moved
you get squeezed out so anyway I'm
[__] totally losing my train of
thought here uh what the hell was the
government part of the the the city that
people don't care about what was they
taught and it's gone just like that ah
Jesus what happened
there was a thought there
and I was walking towards it and I got I
got distracted along the [__] way oh
I know
[__] food how [__] food is nothing but
if they have some new if there's a new
[__] area that real estate agents
you know who are all in ridiculous shape
now and have head shots and Botox and
all of this [__] [__] for some reason
like they've all gone Hollywood
all right and they have an insatiable
appetite to sell [__] real estate and
buy more [__] for themselves they go to
some [__] neighborhood
that isn't safe because nobody gives a
[__] and they let it go to hell and
rather than helping that out how do we
fix that neighborhood up
what do we do we have real estate agents
rename the neighborhood something else
which then that Peaks people with
money's interest
like you know like Hell's Kitchen I
remember back in the day Hell's Kitchen
you know when they wanted people to go
in and pay way too much money for
apartments there they changed it to
Clinton
I don't know why they called it Clinton
I'll tell you why because New York's a
bunch of [__] liberals
does anybody else just sit back and just
watch those those uh political
clips
on social media and just watch how
[__] hypocritical liberals and
[__] conservatives are
like the past that conservatives are
giving Donald Trump right now during
this [__]
whatever the [__] is going on with him
where he's sitting there going yeah I
wouldn't pick you you know I hope you
don't hope you're not offended but this
guy's a babbling idiot
like if I was his lawyer I'd be like
dude shut the [__] up he's a babbling
[__] idiot right and he's just saying
rude [__] to the person that's
interviewing him because he feels he's
above being questioned right and all
these [__] mouth-breathing [__]
conservatives alikes yeah I love this
guy you know he's [__] honest it's
like dude they're talking about a rape
case here
like what what what what what is what is
it about here to find it funny and to
miss this guy because you guys with the
same [__] people calling out Clinton
for going to Epstein Island and being a
[__] pedophile right and you know it
was funny then liberals never said [__]
about that when it came to Clinton but
then Donald Trump gets a little [__]
rapey rapey right little rape case and
now they're all over him all those guys
[__] disgusting
oh big billy comes walking in and all
his accusations don't mean [__]
I [__] hate all of those people
I shouldn't hate him because then it
that just takes
energy out of my day
but I've completely given up on uh
politics I just don't think enough
people have an ability
to uh
I I don't even I just don't understand I
mean all the information is out there
the Federal Reserve that's what you want
to undo that's what you want to go after
that's what we have to take back we got
to take back our money supply and not
have it [__] printed by a private
Corporation
why doesn't a president just send a
platoon of a [__] one platoon of army
guys down there and say hey guess what
this [__] is over we don't owe you any
more money we're starting over again go
[__] yourself
foreign
why can't we do that
everybody's too all right I'm on my
[__] I gotta get off the [__]
let's talk sports everybody let's get to
bread and circus
[__] Washington can't handle [__]
Trump
Washington can handle any of Washington
handles us they got us watching ties
I like the blue ones I like the red ones
ah
anyway
the Celtics have a game seven today
against the 76ers I'm pretty confident I
think we're going to win it
but I I you know Doc Rivers had a lot of
work to do
because I saw that 76ers team quit
at the end of the game and
I kind of wish they didn't quit
because I feel like Doc Rivers is an
unbelievable coach who will know how to
motivate that turn that around and get
them to play
um I'm really looking forward to the
game though because that was sort of how
I got baptized into watching the NBA
back when I I was a kid and it was
bigger than life to me it was those
great Celtic 76ers games
and they always win seven games and it
was Bird versus Dr J everybody talks
[__] Bird magic and all of that [__]
dude before that
was the [__] Philadelphia 76 and if
you wanted to get to the finals you had
to go through that [__] team or the
final I always forget which one says
final Stanley Cup Final or Finals NBA
final or finals I forget they're
I think it's the NBA final
Stanley Cup finals
and that always has to be like there's
always that one dude there's only it's
final there's only one
NBA final
like they're just like you know those
wordsmiths
they're just so enamored with how
[__]
you know they just love when when
somebody says uh
Etc or something that they go it's Etc
and that like literally makes their
weekend
that's going to be an interesting group
of people huh word Smith's hanging out
with each other
what'd you do this weekend Oh you
wouldn't believe it
you can't believe this I was going out
to get a coffee and I heard somebody say
etc
did you say something oh I had to
I had to they were so pissed but I
didn't you know me
I don't give a [__]
um
anyway the Lakers
closed out the ball kicking Warriors
right what's his face he's not dirty
that Derrick Brook guy oh he's filthy
people in Memphis Derrick Brooks the
heart of our [__] team that [__]
[__] out on the Warriors is filthy
Bill Clinton's a good guy
um
oh [__] God damn it spilling [__]
water all over the place I swear to God
I cannot
the second
I spill water like a [__] toddler
dude
this thing was it was a can
oh free advertising a can of liquid
death
on the [__] goddamn floor
open
and I'm talking to you guys and you know
me I like to talk with my hands I make a
big sweeping generalization and I figure
my hand should do the same thing oh look
what it does just spills it all over the
[__]
foreign
you would spill [__] and your
grandparents were over there remember
how mad they get
there was a clip look at this hair look
what you did here Jason look at this
right here you see look at this look at
it
what have you done here look at this
here look at this here they just [__]
commentate the whole time
and all you're doing is looking at the
old age spot on top of that [__] head
like is that what happens
is that the end of this ride
you know
you got liver spots on top of your head
while you [__]
yell at a two-year-old that's related to
you
um
all right
sorry about that I apologize especially
to the mothers I don't know how you do
what it is you do
you know I love how they act like this
they don't have a partner
like like single moms all right I get
that
I get that you you Bank some guy and he
didn't wear a condom congratulations I'm
not kidding what about divorcees
anyway this is the [__] Lakers
you know doing what they do buying other
people's Talent
you know I swear to God if they got rid
of free agency the Lakers would never
win another title they literally cannot
put a team together of their own [__]
players but I'll tell you what they can
do
those [__] know who to buy
because everybody's doing it but they
know who to buy
the Los Angeles other people's players
they're looking great versus trying to
tell me that [__] the Denver Nuggets
are going to beat him in six that's what
he's saying but first he also said
that he he is a Knicks fan Was Not
Afraid of the Miami Heat and I tried to
tell my my
half Sicilian friend I was like you
don't want any part of Jimmy Butler
Jimmy Butler's coming to town and you
you you're gonna wish that he [__]
gets off at the wrong stop
um
anyway I don't know [__] about hoop I
really don't I don't know who's left
like if we beat the 76ers then we go on
to play
oh the Miami Heat you [__] idiot you
were just talking about him all right
oh okay well you know
I kind of feel like whoever wins this
series loses to the heat
that's what I think but uh getting back
to it though
is like I I've like
the early 80s the [__] like 1980 to
Philadelphia 76ers is one of my favorite
teams of all time
you know uh the Daryl Dawkins ones into
the Moses Malone I talk about them all
the time I [__]
those [__] guys could play and they
had Dr J who was Michael Jordan before
Michael Jordan came
just [__] it Above the Rim
um
I remember we talked about that when he
he went up for the dunk and those guys
these Baseline
and he [__]
I think two people went up to block it
so then he brought the the ball down
and he windmilled it around ducked his
head went underneath the hoop and then
reversed laid it up like no one had ever
done some [__] like that ever I know all
the young kids will watch a little do
you know like [__] five things again
well that's because they saw everybody
saw him do it and realized it was
possible
um
so anyway
uh
uh over to the NHL Toronto Maple Leafs
all right well we'll say this they won a
playoff series
so they finally you know they they they
crawled out of the hole a little bit
they lose to the [__] Florida
Panthers who look look who's in the
[__] Eastern Conference Finals your
own Florida Panthers and I am excited to
see them face the Carolina Hurricanes
because I think in this Carolina
hurricane
series they're gonna face something
a challenge that they have not they have
they have yet to be faced with
a challenge they they haven't faced yet
in the playoffs which is something
called defense
I don't think the Bruins played great D
on them and I will tell you or the very
least we just [__] kept letting him
get up off the mat
um but the Toronto [__] Maple Leafs
those first three games was the the
defense was
[__] atrocious
they were giving him like a three foot
cushion they were like escorting them
into the zone
um
I don't understand it the only thing I
can say is I feel like it's it's a
symptom of they took the red light out
of the game there's the stretch pass so
now 99 of the people are super fast
you know unbelievable with the puck
finesse players and nobody takes the
body anymore but you can still forcheck
I feel like that one the last two
[__] games Toronto finally showed up
to the series and played and they went
one and one imagine if they did that
from game one
um so we shall see
because I'm not buying the Florida
Panthers until they beat Carolina
because
um
I don't know I feel like as much as the
Bruins had one of the greatest [__]
regular season of all time I just still
don't feel like
you know we're still just missing
we don't have any Grit and that's what
you need that's a main [__]
ingredient you just got it you got it
like the Panthers they they got nothing
but that they're like [__]
like Relentless you know what's
reminding me of like they've run so far
reminds me of when the Canadians
won it in 1993 although they had better
series I feel like their series were
closer that was one of the if it wasn't
the Canadians it would be my favorite
run to the cup ever I mean it was but
but as a hockey fan
just watching that
and then Patrick Wah the greatest
goaltender of all time as I'm as far as
I'm concerned just shutting everybody
down and this [__] I don't know what
seed they were but they were supposed to
be gone by the first or second round
they won the whole damn thing
um and then those same fans a couple
years later booed Patrick Wa out of
their organization
and there they sit
30 years later cupless
laughs
I mean they haven't been a dynasty in 50
years
it's getting bad like I don't know how
much longer they can sit there and talk
about act like they they are the
Pinnacle of hockey yeah historically
historically you are but dude we're
talking we're going back half a century
all right you haven't won the Stanley
Cup
since before Ronald Reagan
uh I'm sorry I've been a dynasty since
before Ronald Reagan so I was like
dominating the [__] League
um
it's been pretty pedestrian since 1980.
since night okay just for Canadian fans
to put it into perspective since 1980
you've only won one more cup than the
Bruins and we never win it so
I [__] on Bruins toast maybe you can
hear the information
that's all I'm trying to do here people
Edmonton Oilers got back against the
wall down three to two they gotta win
two against the [__] Vegas Knights
these expansion teams might be two
expansion teams might be the Vegas
Knights versus the Seattle cracker
Seattle cracking
playing the Dallas Stars
um
wait a second
this could be four expansion teams
like modern day Florida Panthers
verse the Seattle Kraken and the Knights
verse well Carol uh
wait a minute Carolina Hurricanes were
the Hartford Whalers they've been around
long enough that's back to the 70s
stand close though
all right is this even a podcast anymore
when did the Panthers come into the
league
I know Pavel Bure ended up there
so it's at least 30 years ago isn't it
Florida Panthers Florida Panthers
it's a good time to be in Miami yeah
Florida Panthers are killing it Miami
Heat are killing it
you know
[__] broads down there got plenty of
cocaine you know it's a good time
1993. they've been around for 30 years
Seattle cracking are like two years old
Vegas Knights are like what six seven
years old
let's look up the Hartford Whalers this
is the kind of [__] that I'm interested
in when they ask do you know us history
I'm just like well in a you mean like
sports the history of sports in the
United States yeah I'm pretty good on
that I could do well on that in Jeopardy
I feel
found in 1972 they were the New England
Whalers then they became the ah FID
Whalers they were in the World Hockey
Association starting from 1971 until
1974.
um they relocated to a hot fit in 1974.
the Hartford Civic Center
um
sell out crowd the franchise remained in
Hartford until relocated North Carolina
in 1997-98.
ah it's a shame
you know what happens people move on
and you know what guys like me get sad
um
okay uh
oh I didn't say when the pre-sale was
for those dates that I was talking about
I just saw that Niagara Falls and I was
looking at it and it just reminded me of
that clip of that guy who went to the
Negro uh
Negro League Hall of Fame
like the fact not only did he say that
that the guy next to him is like nodding
like yup that's where we went
uh if he writes his career God help him
if he ever goes to Niagara Falls
he's going to be like saying Niagara
Niagara Niagara before he gets on
[__] TV again all right artist
pre-sale Wednesday May 17th at 10 A.M
local with code Burr uh promoter and
local pre-sales Wednesday May 17th at 10
A.M local
General on sale Friday May 19th at 10
there's a lot of local in there
um
all right if you want to email the
podcast by the way
all right you can send an email to the
Monday Monday dot morning wait
why is it underlined and [__] red I
can't tell
I think it's Monday morning podcast at
gmail.com or it might be Monday dot
Morning podcast
[__] enough
that's my own goddamn podcast and I
don't know
Jesus Christ all right game time
everybody
let's do a little ad reads here game
time you know buying tickets buying
tickets to your favorite events
shouldn't be stressful game time is the
fact game time is fast and easy it's a
fast and easy way to buy tickets for all
the sports music comedy and theater near
you with killer deals on last minute
tickets and their best price guarantee
you can stop stressing over tickets and
start getting hyped for the fun you're
going to be having game time is the
place for the last minute ticket deals
forget planning months in advance you
got [__] to do
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the day of the event get exclusive
Flash Deals on tickets for football
basketball baseball concerts comedy
theater and more the game time guarantee
means you'll always get the best price
if you find ticket ill if you find
tickets in the same section and Rose for
Less game time will credit you 110
percent of the difference
110 percent
of the difference
uh that's like up the ticket costs a
hundred dollars
they give you 110 uh it's the fastest
growing ticketing app in the country for
a reason get images of your seat before
you buy be funny if they just took
pictures of the seat not your view uh
get images of your seat before you buy
so you know exactly what to expect when
you arrive buy tickets in a matter of
seconds two TAPS in your set tickets are
sent directly to your phone so you never
have to dig through your email that's
great
this is some [__] for an old man like me
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code Burr b u
r r for twenty dollars off your purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code b u r r for twenty dollars
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed
all right fume everybody it's f u with
an umlat m
you know cold turkey may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit
fube is an Innovative
award-nominated device that does just
that what makes fume different instead
of electronics fume is completely
natural instead of vapor fume uses
flavored air
and instead of harmful chemical
chemicals
fume uses all natural delicious flavors
you get it instead of bad fume is good
it's a habit you're well tell me about
the flavors
we got a chocolatey eclair mix there
Mist I can't even talk today it's a
habit you're free to enjoy it makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable parts and
magnets for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do
this is for all the fiends out there
giving your fingers a lot to do which is
helpful but for
distressing de-stressing
and anxiety while breaking your habit oh
man they broke that word up over like
two two lines d e Dash stressing
[__] made my my little brain do a
somersault there I need to take a break
here something
is something we all put off because it's
hard
uh but switching to fume is easy
enjoyable and even fun fume has served
over 100 000 customers and has thousands
of success stories and there's no reason
it can't be you all right join fume and
accelerating Humanities break up from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to
tryfume.com t-r-y-f-u-m.com
and use code bird to save 10 percent off
when you get the journey packed today
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m dot c-o-m sorry trifum.com
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Burr to
save an additional 10 off your order
head to tryfume.com
to save an additional 10 off your order
today good luck quitting smoking
um all right
moving away from a young lady oh now
we're the listeners people finally
we're going to get some intelligence on
this podcast have to listen to me
yammering on for a good the better part
of 38 minutes
uh you know moving away from a young
lady
uh dear Bill Burr of writes
if you know I got my kids watching
Schoolhouse Rock now
and they love that one I'm Just a Bill
yes I'm only a bill they're like Dad is
singing about you
and then they like interjection
so when you're happy hooray three is a
magic number verb that's what's
happening in 5 10 15 20 they like that
one too
and then the one that they weren't into
that used to always bum me out to was
that one if I could skate
a figure eight
it would be great it's all like [__]
[__] creeping me out
um
although she does nice crossovers when
she's [__] skating there I love the
podcast and I'm a fan of yours your
advice has kept me going through the
dullness and slog that is law school oh
my God
I have a couple friends of mine got
through law school and I used to just
look at the books that they had to read
and read about those cases
I mean you you gotta love it
you know
I don't give a [__] how much your
parents push you into becoming a lawyer
you have to love that [__] to pass the
bar
oh my God [__] that hats off to anybody
that can do it and hats off to the
lawyers out there they always get like
such a bad [__] rap like their
scumbags you know like it's not their
clients like there's no good lawyers out
there it's just like anything else it's
like comedians there's some good ones
there's some bad ones and there's some
ones that that shouldn't be [__]
doing it right lawyers are the same way
all right there's always the day vatel
out there I mean there's a David tell
lawyer out there that's what I'm going
to say all right
this person says I'm a 27 year old guy
graduating from law school this week
congratulations I've known this lovely
young lady
for two years now
uh she is 23 goes to law school with me
and is the year below me in school she
is very much the nerdy type but is
attractive smart and really is the total
package
uh we are both Runners and ran together
constantly until she broke her kneecap
on her run a few months ago and a few
days before
she realized it was broken she ran 10
miles on it total badass
all right so what's the problem we just
finished the school year
and the night before she leaves we went
out to dinner with some friends then one
thing led to another and we ended up
spending the night together
but didn't go all the way because
I'm the first guy she's kissed
wait a second
I just got lost there this is to check
your width of the chicks you were out to
dinner with
wait wait wait wait wait wait I'm twice
a guy
I've known this okay so you know you
knew this lady oh okay so you've been
running together she's been waiting for
you to do that for [__] years buddy
congratulations that's what I'm guessing
um the problem is I will be moving away
across the country and I'm concerned
about starting a new relationship right
now especially because I have to study
for the bar over the next few months and
then start my new career as a law then
what the [__] did you kiss it for what
wait a minute
were you drinking ah Jesus anyway on the
other hand though I really do like this
girl she's a total sweetheart and I
would probably regret losing her any
advice from you and the lovely Mia would
be greatly appreciated thanks and go
[__] yourself hey man you're going to be
here first don't break her heart all
right unless you have good intentions
with this person just leave it at the
kiss and she'll get over with it don't
don't okay
coming out of her shell
all right
I would say that I'd be very careful
this this is a sweetheart of a person
you don't want to be the person that
does that all right
so
um seems to me like you're pretty
focused on your career
you know
but
yeah
you have to answer that one dude because
I nothing in there
it seems like you were and us you were
assessing a draft pick
you know more you know ran on you know a
broken kneecap for 10 miles total badass
smart attractive really is the total
package
the total package like you're ordering
cable I'm just not feeling love here
buddy I'd say leave her alone
um that's my advice
and I don't think you're gonna do it I
think you're gonna [__]
I I think you're not I don't think
you're gonna listen to me that that's my
prediction all right rat Park study
hello Mr burr from Calgary Calgary all
right am I saying it wrong Calgary
Calgary uh I wanted to ask you if you
knew about the Rat Pack Rat Park study
done in Simon Frazier University
British Columbia Canada how in the [__]
would I know that
I can't even say it I thought it was Rat
Pack Rat Park in the 60s a professor
allowed rats
to hydration sources
okay a lot of rat 2 t w o hydration
sources one was water and one was
cocaine infused
the study concluded the rats would
rapidly overdose on cocaine water over
regular water
all right yeah yeah cocaine water that
was what Spa water was in the 1970s
[Laughter]
um in the 70s a student now Professor
thought what if I made a rat Utopia
would happiness overcome
the convenient addiction
the young lad did such
uh did such this setting up a best
cheese plate
yeah come on people try to proofread
this [__] I can't even read it when you
wrote it correctly
maybe the the young lad did just that
setting up a best cheese plate a ferris
wheel
the [__] kind of brat wasn't going to
Ferris wheel a waterfall the rats were
making babies and starting a community
the study concluded that the rats only
did cocaine water
on the weekends
what
that doesn't make any sense how the [__]
do they know it's the weekend PS my
mother is addicted to your podcast I
have to close the windows she laughed so
hard dude what do you do there was so
much missing there you just [__] with
me
so there was a cheese plate a ferris
wheel a waterfall the rats were making
babies and starting Community the study
concluded that the rats only did the
cocaine water on weekends that just
sounds like that was just a big jerk off
to me like there's no [__] they don't
rats don't work a five-day week and then
take two days off
yeah they get Memorial Day Off
from spreading plagues
all right mispronounced sayings
oh I heard another one this week
I gotta read this one to you
let me see I I write them down all the
time
um
no [__] Captain Obvious
technically it's not wrong but you say
no [__] Sherlock
and then usually go all right let's hear
it for Captain Obvious this person
combined both and said no [__] Captain
Obvious
it doesn't even sound good
and I'm adding that to he's not the
brightest bulb to come down the pipe
you're a piece of dirt that I wouldn't
piss on if you were on fire I don't know
how Dirt catches on fire and they should
know each other like clockwork
um
all right I'm not these aren't really
mispronounced as much as they're just
com they're combined you're combining
sayings they're just saying them wrong
um hey Barista Bill uh writing to you in
response to saying that people
mispronounce
I have a co-worker that always says it's
a blessing in the skies in the skies
hahaha
I get it yeah because that's how you
hear and you're thinking it's like a
religious thing it's as opposed to being
a blessing in disguise
how is the former not obvious because
people are religious so they think it's
God like Anyway the person goes it
drives me absolutely up the wall what
the [__] what a blessing in the skies
even mean for anyone confused let me
explain if a tree falls on my car and my
insurance payout allows me to purchase a
better vehicle that unfortunate event
was a blessing in disguise yeah it's
because good came out of an initially
bad situation Jesus Christ people
any who love the yada yada yada and go
[__] yourself
I like the explanation afterwards that's
great
it was a good example
blessing in disguise because you're
looking at it you're like that's a
terrible thing
and then you get a better thing Bill why
don't you explain his example like you
came up with it all right you're right
blessing in the skies
uh pronounced sayings dear Billy
freckles Burr
uh you've been in aviation long enough
to have a call sign
in fighter Aviation
we write it as depicted above
and would then introduce yourself as
good morning I am Billy Burr call sign
freckles you're welcome
oh is that like Maverick are you Goose
I'm freckles I love freckles
oh freckles coming in hot
Here Comes freckles getting a [__]
sunburn in the cat pit
uh I'm a pro military tactical fire
fighter pilot
uh uh with many hours in multiple
Advanced airframes that I won't list
here but today I am not writing about
Aviation oh you just figured you'd throw
your dick on the table
I wanted to know all about it you got me
all [__] interested nothing happened
uh but rather about a common
misunderstood saying that makes me want
to throw throw heads through walls every
time I hear it muttered
the common saying that is used
incorrectly
is chomping at the bit
is that not how you say it that's how I
say it what most what most don't know is
that the actual saying is champing
c-h-a-m-p-i-n-g champion at the bit and
it originates from the action
of a horse clamping down on their bit
repeatedly and Restless when they are
getting ready to race run Etc
obviously the bit being the part of the
horse's attack that sits in the mouth
used for control
now knowing this information you can
really go one of two ways you can use it
to sound like a magnanimous [__]
when correcting someone to inflate your
delegate delicate ego not recommended to
you can use the saying correctly when
queried
uh use the opportunity
to teach someone something and not be a
[__] I will let you decide queried is
that what that word means what's so
funny is I'm making fun of people well I
can't even read out loud
let me see this champing at the bit
I had no idea that's like I always
thought I was I'll be your Huckleberry
and it's your huckle Bearer a
huckleberry is one of the person that
carries helps to carry your casket
I learned that the other day on [__]
Instagram I thought it was Huckleberry
huckleberry
champagne at the bit
uh champ at the bit is to show
impatience at restraint and be restless
I'll answer that later
oh okay so
so it's not only being impatient you're
impatient with restraint and being
restless so I would imagine a human
being is champing at the bit when
they're [__] standing in a line at
TSA and the [__] [__] had all this
time to take the [__] out of his pockets
and he waits till he gets up there to do
it uh it comes from something said about
horses when they bite their bits
repeatedly and restlessly they champ
yeah because they don't like that
[__] thing in their mouth they don't
want somebody on their back telling them
which way to go champing at the bit
everybody
chomping at the bit yeah that's what I
that's why I say chomping at the pit
champion at the bit all right Segway
thank you sir
queried I gotta look up that word
queried
when one gay guy stabs another no queer
I don't think it would sound like
parried queried
here we go
query uh past participle I have no idea
what a participle is
or dangling participle or predicate
predicate nominative remember all that
[__] remember diagramming sentences
it was just like why are you doing this
by like
we're all talking we all understand each
other why do I need to know
this it was literally like the geometry
of talking
it's like why am I why do I need to know
theories about triangles I'm I'm not
going to become an engineer here all
right many okay ask a question about
something especially in order to express
one's doubt about it or check its
validity or accuracy oh so if I would be
queried because people would be going
like wait a minute now I think it's
chomping at the bit you know what this
might be one of the most informative
[__] emails I ever got
champing at the bit
I'm definitely saying that that actually
sounds better yeah he's champing at the
bit
chopping
that's when you go actually
it's champing
champing at the bit
champing is as a horse Biting Down on
the bit
it's impatient and it's Restless due to
restraint the restraints put on it
that's what it is
Champion why wouldn't they just say
chomping
I'm just going to look up champing
this is a [__] rap oh my God am I
becoming a Wordsmith champing
some reason shampooing came up
what
uh because I have this on French God
damn it I'll have to look it up some
other time which means I'll never do it
somebody else look it up and tell me
what it means all right Segway and
Segway
dear Billy Bonham booties
greeting from Ireland grading some iron
and you recently brought up a confused
up confused words
saying on the podcast
and I wanted to write you can listen to
my bad Irish action throughout all this
you're gonna wanted to write in to raise
awareness on something that's been
driving me crazy for years now Segway
better Segway
okay Segway rhymes with leg Segway
means an uninterrupted transition from
one piece of conversation music movie
scene Etc to another seg leg Segway for
example in the Beatles album Abbey Road
there's a Segway where carry that weight
transitions into the song The End
another segue is between the songs
parabola
parabola by Tool
where one song Blends into the next I'm
too dumb to read these words people what
a lot of people end up saying is
Segway Segway is a brand
Segway
oh my God I'm saying it wrong
it's a brand I don't know how to say it
let me let me I gotta look up Segway and
am I saying I'm saying it wrong
wow this this whole bit was supposed to
make fun of other people and it's really
just making fun of me
Segway pronunciation
it says Segway this might be some Irish
[__] dude I don't know how you say it
over there but we say both the same way
I think
Segway is a brand product it is the Paul
Blart Podium with the wheels that is
most commonly used by fat Americans
while sightseeing on flat terrain oh
[__] you your Irish [__] it's not our
fault you live on half a [__] Island
we got land over here okay we got places
to go uh it's the combination of the
word seg and Whey plus way since it
describes a way of segwaying from one
place to so how do you say the first one
oh he's just saying seg
rhymes with you're saying the first one
s-e-g-l
s-e-g-u-e you just say it like leg but
with an s seg
I don't know what you're saying here sir
I'm sorry
you know I'm assuming we're both white
we both speak English and we can't
communicate because of that body of
water it's just separated us for too
long
um anyway
unfortunately however Segway is used
more and more incorrectly in place of
seg
I'm just gonna keep calling it said
because I don't know how he wants me to
say this segue
uh a Sega you uh it surprised me how
often I hear intelligent podcasters
speakers
Etc mix up these words it's getting to
the point where it's used incorrectly
more often than than it is used
correctly yeah and then it becomes
accepted
when the Oxford dictionary just Taps out
and just says all right
mouth breathers win again the Segway
inventor Jim has Hazelden died in 2010
not on his Segway
when the Segway he was riding drove off
a cliff while he was out walking his dog
I hope this mistreatment of the word
follows a similar fate
that's not true
that's just no [__] way he died by
his own invention is he the first guy
since Frankenstein that that happened to
oh Jimmy Segway
Jimmy
that go look goes up Hendricks
has zeldin death
no [__] way
Jesus Christ look at the beak on that
guy he invented a Segway what happened
to the guy who invented the Segway the
millionaire owner of Segway company has
died after falling from Cliffs while
riding one of his first modified
scooters oh no he was 62.
62 year old people fall out of a golf
cart and die
um now I'm fascinated can somebody and
phonetically write out how to how to
pronounce
according to my uh American English it's
still Segway
okay sayings hey Billy ball bag long
time listener first time emailer here's
a saying I heard a friend say wrong
uh he was talking about some issue at
work and referred to it as a
Doggy Dog worlds oh no
oh no
instead of a dog eat dog world what a
[__]
it's a doggy dog world
oh that's a door he's like adorably
stupid
as opposed to me he was annoyingly
stupid greetings from Northern Ireland
loved the podcast in your work you
[__] freckled [__]
you work on the Mandalorian is brilliant
oh thank you you know the space [__]
really seem to enjoy my work on the
lightsaber program there
um and I appreciate the compliments
I gotta add doggy dog world
um all right this is fantastic we just
can keep going with this and people
mispronounce because you guys are
helping me out too because I I think a
lot of people listening to this podcast
also I said chomping at the bit and I
also say Segway I don't know how else to
say it
um
I don't know I don't know what to tell
you but anyways that is the podcast
everybody go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on you
on Thursday